[Musique]
rechargez vos très particulière avec des
personnages en situation en mouvement et
à cette époque talent est en pause était
assez long donc le mouvement il était
pas souvent floue sur les photos on
trouve donc pas très utilisable photo
s'achète dks épices trinité janvier 1
99% et il en est jean 2 aux antilles
m'intéresse au moins deux belles photos
c'est le fauteuil qui me permettent de
trouver dessus un personnage qui soit
dans une position qui m'inspire une
nouvelle histoire pour le mettre dans un
nouveau décor et un portier en fait une
histoire sans parole ça se passait entre
la fin par exemple une famille comme ça
on peut la détourner de son lieu et il
veut inventer une nouvelle histoire
c'est après ce genre de photos que même
si elles sont plein mouvement mais par
contre ça permet d'avoir des personnages
c'est intrigant
[Musique]
c'est les albums de famille si un peu
partout dans toutes les familles là j'ai
eu de la chance parce que celui ci par
exemple chez beaucoup de scènes très
sympa et des dépositions fera que le
photographe défaveur de la mise en scène
de ces photos elles sont disposés en
triangle ou des horizontales donc ça
pour moi c'est très très riches parce
que ça me permet d'avoir effectivement
de bonnes bases de travail
ensuite je vais je l'étais tour et je
les sortir de là et je les plongées à
lille en l1 12 pour touver km
[Musique]
où est il
quelquefois ya trente ou quarante 40
images différentes pour recomposer qu un
accord secret avec avec des fonds des
personnages s'appellent des objets on
peut changer aussi ont pu intervenir sur
sur l'image
je mesure le personnage la porte une
sorte d'épée je me transforme et je peux
les matins à ce moment de musique je
peux l'emmener ailleurs que dans son
antre cette histoire là en fait c'est le
but d'ailleurs cette journée alors c'est
pas que les séries le comilev s'ils ont
salué l'intérêt d'opel que la latence et
les couper en deux ils n'auront pas les
mêmes jambes ou héros pas la même teinte
ou voilà c'est au déluge commence un peu
comme ça même si j'ai une idée un petit
peu de là où je veux aller mais
quelquefois aussi l'image moonen sac en
fait je ne sais tu pas du tout
quelquefois j'ai fait une image deux
trois quatre fois ça n'est jamais qu'à
un moment donné ça
on communique en fait l'image et voir
communiquer ça me mène quelque part
[Musique]
aussi c'est une nouvelle vie pour eux
aussi une source d'inspiration parce que
j'ai une sorte d' échange avec avec ses
personnages qui sont plus là et on sait
que cette notion aussi de la disparition
des gens des êtres jeu pas qu'on va le
montage en fait je ne suis pas du
montage une photo montage comme ça se
faisait où ça se fait encore aujourd'hui
à l'elysée non non non je veux vraiment
que les photographes qui voit l'image et
un doute quoi c'est une photo c'est pas
une photo aux avantages soutien jouets
qui se douter que en fait ça interroge
[Musique]
merci à lui dans la masse il aux séries
il s'agit de la route
[Musique]
rien dans los caminos c'est ma vie
lointain tega